Je pense donc que ça fait sens de chercher des moyens
de mitiger cet impact.
Nous devons mener des recherches pour ça.
Nous devons comprendre la science sous-jacente.
J'ai constaté qu'il y a un thème récurrent qui s'est développé chez TED :
« la peur ou l'espoir »,
en d'autres mots : « la créativité ou la prudence ».
Naturellement, nous avons besoin des deux.
Il n'y a pas de solution miracle.
Et ceci n'en n'est pas une.
La science doit toutefois nous dire quels sont les choix possibles
pour nourrir à la fois notre créativité et notre prudence.
Je suis optimiste quant à notre avenir,
mais je ne le suis pas parce que je pense que nos problèmes sont insignifiants.
Je suis optimiste parce que je pense que notre capacité à gérer nos problèmes
est plus grande que ce qu'on imagine.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissement)
[Cette présentation a initié une grande controverse à TED2017.]
[Nous vous invitons à lire les discussions en ligne]
[et à découvrir les autres points de vue.]